c'est avec le sourire que le maestro
raphaël paillard et débarque à montréal
je suis tellement ravie d'être ici
justement heureux et très honoré d'être
le prochain directeur musical de
l'orchestré symphonique de montréal
[Musique]
originaire du venezuela rafael paillard
et a appris la musique et le corps
français à l'âge de 14 ans en tant que
chef d'orchestre il a rayonné avec
l'orchestré de lyster de belfast puis
avec le philharmonique de vienne qu'il
demeure le directeur musical de
l'orchestré symphonique de san diego
[Musique]
musique a déjà dirigé le sm en tant que
chef invité en 2018 puis en 2019
il avait laissé une forte impression le
maestro connaît bien la musique et ça
s'entend bien mais il connaît moins bien
le français qu il est en train
d'apprendre à raison de cinq heures par
jour
alors oui les one life to de la commune
[Musique]
âgés de 40 ans et avec ses allures de
vedettes du rock my troupe ayari
deviendra le neuvième directeur musical
de l'om est le premier sud américain à
obtenir le poste
il devra chausser les souliers du
maestro kent nagano qui a profondément
marqué le paysage musical montréalais on
a vraiment senti que rachel paillard est
elle à avoir une belle une belle
relation avec notre communauté et ça
c'était fondamental très sensible comme
personne mais c'est sûr qu'il ya un air
de d'enthousiastes qu'on voit pas très
souvent
avec sa longue feuille de route et sa
virtuosité raphaël paillard et ne
laissera pas les mélomanes indifférent
on pouvait pas souhaiter mieux comme
chef un chef
jeune dynamique le monde du tennis à san
rafael nadal et ben moi je peux dire que
maintenant le monde symphonique
montréalais a aussi son raphaël
paillardes raphaël paillard y deviendra
le directeur musical pour la saison 2010
22 2023 de l'osce m
et ce pour une période d'au moins cinq
ans en attendant il participera des
concerts de l'om dont celui qui sera
donnée virtuellement et gratuitement
dimanche à 14h30 certes au traître est
vraiment merveilleux au broyage ici
louche et de primaire radio canada bon
rien
[Musique]